( intro music )
( audience applause )
Shivani: I'm a fourth
generation Kenyan
and I live in a tent
in one of the most beautiful
landscapes in the world,
Samburu in Northern Kenya.
It is here that I
protect one of Kenya's
most iconic species; the lion.
In under a century we have lost
over 90% of our planet's lions.
The situation in Kenya
is just as serious.
We are down to less than
1,000 lions in our country.
What's happening?
Why are we losing so many lions?
In Northern Kenya,
where I live and work,
lions are running out of space.
As human numbers increase
and more livestock comes along,
there's more pressure
that's being put on lions.
Unfortunately, when this
happens, lions go out,
they come into close contact
with the local people
and they cause conflict.
Livestock such as
camels, donkeys, cows,
they're much easier to
kill than a wild animal,
like an impala or a gazelle.
This happens often in our area.
Lions target livestock
but this causes a lot
of anger and resentment
amongst the local people
whose livelihoods depend
on this livestock.
They often will go
out and retaliate
and they will shoot,
spear or poison lions.
Together with my team in Samburu
an incredibly dedicated,
passionate and enthusiastic
group of elders,
warriors and women.
We run the Ewaso Lions Project.
Our mission is to
promote the co-existence
between lions and people
that share this landscape.
We do this through
a number of community
and awareness
education programs.
One of our main ones
is a program called
Warrior Watch.
Warriors are young men
aged between 15 to 30.
The warrior in the
middle in this picture
his name is Jeneria.
He's a very special young
man who's my assistant.
He came to me many
years ago and he said,
"You know Shivani, my age mates,
my fellow warriors,
why are they not
involved in conservation?
We could do a great job,
if we just involved
all of them."
I said, "Let's
bring them on board.
Let's see, if they want to
be involved in conservation."
He brought over five
warriors from his community
and he asked them.
He said, "Do you guys
want to be involved
in conservation?
Do you want to learn about
why it's important to
conserve these animals?"
They said, "Yes, of course.
We are the eyes and
the ears in the bush.
We see wildlife everyday.
Absolutely involve us."
Thanks to the Big
Cats Initiative
we started with five warriors
and now we've grown
to over 15 warriors
working in this region.
They have various roles.
One of them is to
patrol their areas.
They all live in their villages,
they go out during the day,
they see what's in the area,
they scan it.
If there's predators
in the area,
they communicate that
message back to the herders
who are out there
with their livestock.
We've taught them
how to use GPS's,
so as they're herding
their livestock
they can tell us
what they're seeing.
What amazing wildlife animals
they see during the day.
Both sightings of predators
and also tracks.
You can see in
this picture Precy,
one of our warriors.
He's got his finery, he's
got his knife, his bracelets
and right next to his knife
is a little GPS unit with a pen.
This is all our warriors.
They go out dressed
like this everyday.
This is their
normal way of life.
We asked the warriors,
"In exchange for all this
fantastic wildlife information
that you give to us,
what would you like in return?"
And they said education.
"We've never had
that opportunity
to go to school.
We don't know how
to read and write."
We started a Sunday
school with the warriors
five years ago.
Now I'm very excited to say
that all of our warriors
can read and write,
both in English and our
national language Kiswahili.
( applause )
We evaluated this program
a couple of years ago
to really understand how it
was working in the community
and we were so excited
with the results.
They were very positive.
They showed that the
local people's attitudes
towards predators
have greatly improved
as a result of the
warriors working with them.
The warriors also felt much
more socially empowered
as a result of this project.
The women came to
us and they said,
"You're working with warriors,
you're working with
elders and children.
Where are we?
We want to be involved
in this project as well
and where is our school?
We want to learn how to
read and write as well."
We started a Saturday school
with the women just last year
through a new program
we have launched
called Mama Simba, which
means "mother of lions."
I'm very excited to say
that just in a few months,
much shorter time than
the warriors learned,
( audience laughing )
the women...
( applause )
The women learned how
to read very quickly.
They're very excited about it.
They monitor all the predators
that come to their
villages at night
and they write down little
notes about who's come
and how many times
they've come in a week.
We did conservation
training with the women.
We taught them the importance
of lions and predators
and why conservation is
so essential in this area.
We showed them
the different tracks
because it's all the predators
that come to visit them
at their villages
in the evenings.
The women said to us
we know the tracks,
we know the difference
between hyena
and lion and leopard tracks
but we've never actually
seen these animals.
We've never had a close-up
encounter with a lion.
We hear them at night,
we see their tracks
but we've never seen them.
We said we're gonna change this.
We're gonna take
you all on safari
so you can get to see
what tourists from all
over the world get to see.
Here we are.
( audience laughing )
We took all the women on safari
into the beautiful
Samburu National Reserve.
And of course,
the number one animal
the women wanted
to see were lions.
We were a little worried
because by 11:00 that morning
we had seen nothing, actually,
and the women kept saying to us,
"Where are the lions?
Do they really exist?
We know they exist
because we hear them
but you keep
talking about them.
Where are they?"
We worked really hard
and we were very lucky.
We managed to find two of
our beautiful lionesses,
Nanai and Nabulu,
feeding on a baboon.
The women were very
excited watching this.
At the time,
Jeneria, my assistant,
he was in another car.
He had a lady next to him
who had a little baby.
The baby was getting
a little bit agitated
so he said to me
he's gonna drive off
and leave us with the lions,
and he would let us
know later where he is.
About 10 minutes later
he radioed me
and he said, "Shivani,
come quickly.
Bring the women.
Something amazing
is happening."
I said, "What?
What's more exciting
than watching these
lions eating a baboon."
He said, "Just come, trust me."
I told the women, "Hang on.
We're gonna go drive
to where Jeneria is."
And off we went,
and we found him
and right next to him
was an elephant giving birth.
It was an absolutely
amazing experience.
I have lived in
Samburu for 12 years
and I'd never seen this.
What's even more incredible,
is there's a relationship
between Samburu women
and elephants.
As we watched this birth,
the Samburu women in our cars
were talking to the elephants.
They were talking
to them in Samburu.
They were saying tomononi ai ,
which means--
It's an endearing way
of talking to someone.
They said, "We know
you're in trouble,
we know you and lions,
you're all facing
a lot of problems.
Now we know
and we're going to work
hard to change that."
It was an incredible
experience but word spread
that we had shown a lot of women
an elephant giving birth
and we got messages from
the community saying,
"Take us on Safari.
( audience laughing ) We want
to see elephants give birth."
Took a lot of
convincing to tell them,
every time you go
on safari in Samburu,
you don't actually see
an elephant give birth.
Every year we hold
Lion Kids Camps.
Unfortunately,
children in rural Kenya
don't have positive
experiences with wildlife.
Most of their experiences
are very negative.
They get to see
a cheetah killing a goat,
they get to see
the remains of a camel
after a lion's preyed on it.
They have never really
experienced wildlife
the way I was
lucky to experience
when I was a child.
My parents took me on safari.
I will never forget my
first cheetah sighting,
my first lion sighting.
My first cheetah sighting
happened to be in Samburu
when I was just eight years old.
That has stayed in my mind
and that is why I do what I do.
We have really invested
in these children.
We believe they are
the future conservationists
in this region.
They are the future wardens,
tour guides, rangers
and just wildlife leaders.
Our Kids Camp changes this.
We bring wildlife to
the children closeup.
We give them a much more
positive experience.
Most of these children
had actually never seen a lion
so we show them lions.
We bring them right
next to these lions
so they can get to see
what people from all over
the world get to see.
These two little kids--
This picture was taken
just a couple of weeks ago
at our second annual Kids Camp.
These little kids,
Saiwana and Ltonos
they were sitting next to
me and they were saying,
"We really can't wait
to see our first lion,"
and we did.
We were actually very lucky.
We saw 10 lions that day.
At the back in the picture
you'll see a little brown blob
and that's actually
a big male lion.
These little kids saw him
and their faces say it all.
This is the first
ever lion they've seen
and they kept whispering
to me, "Simba, simba,"
and this is what gives us hope.
Loirish is a lion we
monitored in 2008.
He was the father of many cubs
in both Samburu and
Buffalo Springs Reserves.
He had control over two prides.
Unfortunately, Loirish got into
a lot of trouble last year.
He was leaving the
safety of the parks
and going out and killing
a lot of livestock.
He killed more than 10 camels
just in three months.
We were very worried about this.
We said we have to put
a collar on him now
and so we can really
monitor his movements.
Every time he leaves
we will be able to see
that he's out there
approaching livestock,
we could warn the herders.
This is Letoiye,
one of our warriors,
and Loirish was his lion.
He was looking after Loirish.
Unfortunately we were
not given much time.
Loirish was killed
last year in September.
His head was cut off,
his legs were cut off
and his head was burned
so they would remove
the signs of the collar.
Letoiye, who is in this picture,
he for weeks was in camp
saying to himself and
talking to all of us saying,
"My warriors killed my lion.
How could that have happened?
I will make sure this
doesn't happen again."
This was devastating
for our project
but everyone was
even more determined
to make sure that our lions
don't have the same
fate that Loirish had.
On a more hopeful note,
Naramat who is a female
that we hadn't seen
for many years,
for about three years.
We were driving through
Samburu last year.
We heard the
guinea fowl squawking.
We knew there was
a predator in the area
and we saw this female.
Jeneria and I, we know
the lions very well.
It takes us a couple of
seconds to identify them
but in this case
we were stunned.
We're like, "Who is this lion?"
We pulled out our ID books,
our iPads
which has all the sketches
of the lions,
their ears, their whisker spots,
and finally we identified her.
We said, "Wow this
is Naramat."
She left three years ago.
Where has she been?
This is where she's been.
She had been outside the parks.
She was surviving
with the local people
and what's even more exciting,
she came back with
a little male cub.
A little one year old male cub
who we named Lentim.
This shows that lions
do survive outside
with the local people.
I get asked this question a lot.
"Is there a future for
lions in Northern Kenya?"
Absolutely there's a future.
Our work has shown that.
We had 11 lions a decade ago
and now we're monitoring
over 50 lions in our area.
It's because of the local
people's involvement.
With them invested
in conservation,
there's definitely a hope.
We have an event which
we have every year.
It's the Running for
Lions half marathon
and now the local
people are running
in the name of lions.
Every year the number of
participants increase.
I think they hear that the
prizes are very exciting.
It's prizes of goats.
( audience laughing ) So the
number of people keep coming
and women too.
For the last three
years we've had
more than 20 women
come to run for lions.
This is our camp,
our field base camp
in the Westgate
Conservancy in Samburu.
It's an open area,
it's very remote.
We have no running
water, no power,
no internet, no phones.
We have wildlife
walking through.
We have one little animal
that's not very wild.
He's a little dog.
Keeps us very
well entertained in camp.
It's in this camp
seven years ago
that we set up base.
For many years we actually
never heard lions in our camp
but now over the past year,
we can hear lions in our camp,
and this is incredible.
This is because they feel safer.
The people are much more
willing to live with lions,
they're tolerant of them
and now lions feel that.
They feel safer and we
can hear them at night.
Today, I ask you.
I ask you to support
these initiatives
that are ongoing in Africa,
and to spread the word
about the lion crisis.
We then have hope
that we will continue
to hear lions throughout
the African wilderness
for generations to come.
In Samburu we say ashe oleng.
Thank you very much.
( audience clapping )
( outro music )